um okay let's go let's go maybe to a
local caller from the 508 area code
who's calling today from 508 hey it's
Brandon how you doing hey Brandon were
you calling from I am in the new winds
on air I don't really want to get my
location but uh trying to tell you that
it's not Brockton is it please tell me
it's not Brockton Robbins fine I'm half
kidding but I just saw five away what's
on your mind today
yeah so uh I'm kind of a unique caller I
grew up in a conservative type family
grew up conservative myself through
college and then during college I joined
the military was in the military for a
while while being in college and then I
right now I'm a full-time police officer
okay so why I think because I'm
definitely I feel like I'm in a unique
situation I used to be very conservative
and now I'm super left-leaning yes in
within two jobs or two career paths that
I find that are very conservative so I
find myself all the time you know
debating these issues you know the Air
Show with a Kyle show that was mentioned
before and I know I just find I don't
see many people out there who you know
fit my description who feel the same way
you know that's interesting I mean you
don't without you you know you don't
have to say where you are but I think
there's a lot of places in the 508 area
code which even though they're in
Massachusetts they're relatively
blue-collar conservative places so it
I'm not shocked to hear that the
majority of the people in law
enforcement are relatively conservative
says I think my instinct is from people
I know whatever like the politics are of
a place law enforcement is always
slightly to the right of that so like as
a counterexample in Northampton
Massachusetts where the show started
which is a very left-leaning place the
police department is still quite
left-leaning the police chief right now
is uh is a lesbian officer
and the police participate in the Pride
Parade and all this stuff but still like
in general that that police force is
still to the right of Northampton
Massachusetts if that makes sense so I'm
not super surprised to hear that right
yeah I just it's like that was that you
know work the other night and I you know
everyone thought assumed that because
you know I was police officer that I you
know I felt or I had my political you
know Eileen right yep which is the
opposite of the case right so I don't
know I did I just you know I I like
talking politics I'm like a political
junkie and I love the stuff but I don't
know I just didn't I know I just haven't
found anyone else really who feels the
same way at least in my you know in my
demographic yeah I mean I think I would
look at some of the departments out on
Western Mass I mean but does this cause
does this cause problems for you with
your coworkers
absolutely not because I find I find
them educated about politics and don't
stuff like that and they are very stuck
into identity politics and you know
whatever the president says like you
know is right and yeah that's kind of
like the you know the debates we have
and I'm known as like you know the more
liberal police officer and but no I just
want to also say because I know you get
a lot of people that listen to your show
that you know we are you know people in
law enforcement are out there and we are
we do you know there are some of us that
do think this way so you know I just
wanted to kind of make that known as
well thank you yeah and we have many
left-leaning law enforcement current and
former folks in the membership as well
so I appreciate the phone call yeah
thank you did all right take care and on
that note we will go to a break thanks
to everybody that called in many many
more stories to discuss coming up next